salud en directo América de France 24
más Romero sala me acompaña en el
estudio mar bienvenida buena mañana de
martes hoy vamos a hablar de la
esperanza de vida raíz de la pandemia de
escobit 19 con nuevos datos que han
salido a la luz Buenos días son datos
publicados en la revista nature human
behavior y que nos aclaran algunas
respuestas no todos podemos asumir que
durante el 2020 cuando más duro fue el
impacto de la pandemia de Kobe 19 la
esperanza de vida cayó en globalmente
pero responde también a qué pasó durante
el 2021 y lo primero que vemos es que no
es uniforme hay algunos países como
Bulgaria donde la esperanza de vida cayó
hasta 18 meses en el 2020 y luego siguió
cayendo durante todo el 2021 algo
parecido pasa con Estados Unidos en
menor medida donde no recuperaron esta
esperanza de vida perdida este tiempo no
sino que siguió cayendo durante el 2021
en cambio vemos otros países de España o
Bélgica son otros ejemplos en los que
durante 2021 esta flecha que nos
devuelve digamos hasta el 2019 vemos
cómo se ha recuperado algo de Pues de
esperanza de vida a niveles
prepandémicos y esto De qué nos habla
Pues también de las diferencias en sus
respuestas no En qué hicieron estos
países y empezaron a vacunar cuando lo
hicieron Que tasas de vacunación tienen
que medidas públicas tomaron vemos Esta
correlación entre una respuesta rápida y
alta tasas de vacunación por ejemplo
Bulgaria es uno de los países con menos
tasa de vacunación de toda Europa versus
los que sí Como por ejemplo en España
también muestra que hay países que
tenían problemas de salud preexistentes
que se acentuaron durante la pandemia de
covid 19 y eso es un claro ejemplo en
Estados Unidos por ejemplo no qué pasa
Ahí la mayor parte de países que
lograron recuperar esta esperanza de
vida fue porque lograron brindar con la
vacunación a la población mayor de 80
años que era Pues de las que más sufrió
el impacto del 19 sin embargo en Estados
Unidos Aunque eso también sucedió vemos
que la mortalidad en menores de 60 años
siguió siendo muy grande una de las hipó
por ejemplo es por el gran problema de
diabetes la amplia prevalencia que hay
de diabetes en Estados Unidos como
factor también de riesgo por Kobe 19 y
pues los problemas que aquejan a la
salud pública al acceso en este país
podemos seguir prediciendo Marc que
pasará en el futuro nunca a ciencia
cierta eso Raúl Pero podemos mirar hacia
atrás y ver qué nos dice esto de lo que
puede pasar en el futuro no vamos a ver
un gráfico por ejemplo en el que
muestran la esperanza de vida
precisamente a nivel histórico los años
en los que retrocedió no desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial vemos que la
crisis del covid 19 ha sido la que más
ha afectado a la esperanza de vida y
también que ha sido mucho peor que en
algunas crisis de gripe que vemos en los
años 60 70 por ejemplo no sin embargo
también que vemos pues que son los
países como Francia Italia España
Estados Unidos en los que menos ha
disminuido la esperanza de vida menos
años han tenido en los que esta
retrocedido mientras que hay otros como
Bulgaria Hungría o Rusia en los que
sigue Durante los años han tenido más
problemas no más tropiezo en esta
progresión esto nos puede decir y es uno
de los temores de los expertos que en
los próximos años lo que suceda es que
haya como unos caminos divergentes no
los países que no tuvieron esta
respuesta rápida tarde mucho más en
recuperarse los países que tuvieron una
respuesta pues más eficaz digamos
enseguida vuelvan y a niveles pre
pandémicos Y eso marque digamos unas
desigualdades muy fuertes regionales
entre los países y sus esperanzas de
vida también también vemos por ejemplo
eso en los años posteriores a la Segunda
Guerra Mundial o aquí no aparece pero lo
que pasó con la gripe española en 1918
en general lo que se calcula es que se
tardan apenas un par de años en volver a
recuperar los niveles prepandémicos de
esperanza de vida así que bueno
estaremos pendientes lo que pasa en 2022
para tener conclusiones más certeras así
es más pasamos a otro tema porque hay
nuevos datos que relacionan los
productos alisadores del pelo y el
cáncer sí son datos muy muy importantes
que además reafirman ya pues algunos
otros estudios que se hayan hecho en
este sentido son datos del Instituto
Nacional para consecuencias de la salud
y ambiente de Estados Unidos Cuál es la
principal conclusión básicamente es que
entre las mujeres que no usaban
productos químicos realizado de pelo
desarrollaron cáncer uterino durante sus
70 años de vida un uno como 64% en
cambio las mujeres que usaban
frecuentemente de estos productos de
alisado de pelo esta tasa subió hasta el
4% son cifras relativamente bajas
también porque el cáncer uterino no es
de los más prevalentes en general es
relativamente raro sin embargo vemos que
se dobla se multiplica casi por dos este
más por dos más de por dos de hecho más
que se duplica la tasa de este riesgo
asociado con el alisado de pelo con
estos productos químicos el estudio se
hizo con
33.500 mujeres durante 11 años se les
hizo seguimiento de Soledad Pues
robustez a los datos y precisamente esta
comparación entre las mujeres que no
usaban Y sí usaban los productos porque
sabemos que el cáncer puede venir dado
por muchos factores entonces necesitamos
saber esa tasa que usa que había las
personas que no usaban el producto pero
bueno vemos que sí hay un vínculo sería
un factor más digamos
a quienes afecta más las consecuencias
de los alisadores del pelo marr pues
definitivamente a quienes más lo usan y
sobre todo a quienes más les ha afectado
la presión estética que también existe
alrededor del alisado de pelo escuchemos
ya que las mujeres usan productos para
alisar el pelo más frecuentemente y
suelen iniciar su uso a edades más
tempranas que otras razas Y etnias estos
hallazgos podrían ser más relevantes
para ellas es un factor además muy muy
evitable del que estamos hablando no los
autores del estudio creen que en general
son los metales los formaldehídos o el
bisfenol uno de los productos pues uno
de los componentes que están en estos
realizadores de pelo los que provocan
este pueden aumentar el riesgo de Cáncer
y de nuevo recordar eso no no es
casualidad que sean las mujeres con el
pelo afro un pelo que históricamente es
asociado algo despeinado incluso poco
respetable no que no debería verse así
las que más usan estos productos por lo
tanto las que más afectadas también se
van a ver en el largo plazo Pues por
este riesgo de aumento de cáncer uterino
que existe mar como siempre Muchísimas
gracias por toda la información de salud
mañana con más mañana con más